how's once I want to want to say to hear
that oh yeah go ahead first time we ever
met yeah I know you heard some things I
said this the only reason I'm here is
your little [ __ ] Tiger belly crew I
mean I've been misinformed yeah what do
you call you people the Tiger belly
sleepers yeah what is the line go ahead
I saw there's no clue the rounds sitting
there and your little [ __ ] office
sycophants that's not how we went down
it at all
shame on you know first of all Michael I
would like you lean very funny
I'll tell you the way I wonder if your
version yeah and I'll give mine okay for
the what what are they called again
sleepers okay so every once in a while
because you know Joe Rogan is a stand-up
he's a longtime friend um I've known him
for 20 years 25 years um love them great
guy but um so a lot of you know I'm a
huge UFC fans so who's that little guy
from Sacramento I like right you're a
father man you nice can we hug this and
that but then when I saw Bisbing Michael
you for the first time there I literally
was struck I was just like right and I
try to come up to you and I said you
were very nice but I said hey man I'm a
big fan and you were you know because
when I walk I was at the the grocery
store and people come up to me and go oh
you're very funny and out you want to be
cordial right but I also if that person
that said hide it was Josh Groban right
and it's true right okay and I blew him
off right I bet that Josh Groban would
probably be a little mad so he was at
the Comedy Store where for a small I
don't know who just okay so zero context
and what you say
I'm always at the Opera yeah yeah right
so might when Michael's business there
he said very nice but he cut just walked
away and I wanted some you know man did
you ask no I didn't really he did walk
away already and here's the reality
yeah and I'm not when I say this yeah by
the way by the way massive fan hence why
I'm here is why I drove up from [ __ ]
Orange County Thank You audition and I
waited for three and a half hours 5:30
was half asleep
some coffee now I'm drinking this shy
yes there wait I'm very happy to be here
hilarious to medium I never met you
before I don't
okay getting to the point I uh the
long-suffering missus baseman that's at
home bless her she doesn't get out very
often yeah you know she's got three kids
I travel a lot I took her out we went
out for a nice dinner and went to go
watch some comics and a lot of the time
I'm not trying to say that I'm [ __ ]
big deal or anything like that but a lot
of time you stop and you take pictures
and this and that and then after a while
you gotta say okay because I'm here with
my wife and I've done about ten pictures
in a row while she's standing there like
a [ __ ] lump of cheese right doing
nothing so then after that I'm not okay
all right all right babe let's go in and
then you after that said I'm at now
sorry mate we're done picture time is
all right you should start doing now let
me see some right so when you bear or
not fair sorry if I didn't put I run
them stranger before my wife mmm-hmm
I'm so sorry yeah I know you're the
great and the company stow is your house
and you're totally right it is your
house but we've never met and that's the
mother of my children
right you're in or what and the way is
okay I accept your apology hit your
[ __ ] angel I'm fine it's fine
[ __ ] paws out of my face right now
you worried about father
you weren't to know it he was devastated
though he called me immediately yeah ran
to the parking lot yeah and he was like
you can't but you won't believe what
happened I just go for one right but no
but good as they say this please can I
say this you did give me a photo I did
yes
afterward I remember I was viral Joey
yes with the Yeti with Diaz and I walked
up because when you were talking to Diaz
you know that then I see is my
opportunity and we took the photo you
know what I was just talking out of my
ass right just talking [ __ ] or whatever
thinking that you're ever gonna [ __ ]
hear it it's okay I just say I do it all
the time if I was held accountable every
piece of [ __ ] that came out of my
mouth yeah yeah probably be in prison
yeah you know or you know
excommunication yeah I know yeah you
know I want to say this too is is that
because I never let the truth get in the
way of a good story and write Chinese
you with the Asian see that man what do
you mean with the Chinese proverb
Chinese proverb
[Music]